good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
monday oh my god this morning has felt
like an entire week in and of itself i
didn't even realize it was monday hey
jax how you doing i'm darn good this is
our first official
toast remote in the new setup of course
everything there's room for improvement
but i'm really excited to see how it
goes
me too obviously we spent the last two
weeks getting your remote studio looking
sickening and mission
accomplished um and my remote studio we
like kind of like forgot about so this
morning we have just been
tech girl is back like
maybe they should replace batgirl the
movie with tech girl because she's real
she's sweating and she's doing her best
so our audio should be pretty premium
today video we're going to keep
aesthetic don't jinx it don't jinx it
last time you said that on a monday of a
first set up you know all hell broke
loose
so i think our audio will be audible
yeah hopefully and our video should be
gorgeous because we are
that's true like at the end of the day a
video is only as gorgeous as the girls
in it and we are girls on film too
between claudia wearing a headset and
having a microphone and being back in
the studio you know that it's on and she
will be back to singing we'll have to
see how our remote singing does if we
can sync up but it might just be like a
lot of solos from you which i know
you're really upset about oh
i'm crying tears of sadness
not solos
no oh you mean by
myself no
i'm shy
oh no
um let's talk about the weekend i got
back from florida yesterday and honestly
like the chaotic nature of this morning
has really highlighted like how there is
such a difference in our quality of
lives to be completely honest like this
morning yelling at construction workers
telling them to stop drilling for an
hour i have the sweaty snack on the
planet um and that's just a little bit
about me
yeah you are dearly missed in the
sunshine state and i know that you know
it and i know that you miss us and so
it's not like i have to convince you
that your minister that you should be
missing us like it's just a sad state of
affairs yes
100 and you know what i was like so
emotional yesterday on the way to the
airport and that's my level of emotion
when i know i'm literally coming back in
less than a week so i can't imagine the
next time i leave where i don't have an
actual
set date set trip planned i'm not gonna
be okay no you're not but i think you're
officially a snowbird if that means
being here every other week you or like
we have been in the process of getting
my house ready for you like ordering all
the things that you'll need you know
from the big things to the small things
i literally ordered outdoor furniture
for you otherwise i probably would have
put it off except i'm glad that you
inspired me to do it because now i'm
really excited but down to the shampoo
toothpaste toothbrush so like if you
have a set of your tings in another
state i think that you are officially
you know living between states
no i think i really made it official
last night when i amazon primed a smelly
pillow to your living quarters because
that's really like i home is where the
smelly pillow is yeah
yeah even though i think i had one for
you but sure
you know what now ben can experience the
premium the pleasure the luxury that is
the smelly pillow but sure microphones
sure
sure i got a new microphone because i
wanted us to have matching ones in our
separate studios for like you know i
couldn't let your quality be better than
mine
um
and the brand of this company like every
10 minutes nobody me sure
if they should really like the oxford
miriam
should change the spelling of sure c
s-u-r-e
to sure
s-h-u-r-e and if you're watching on
youtube you can see that it says sure
sure
right above our mic flags and every time
i see these microphones they spark joy
and a hundred and our other ones heil
no
they were heil
the the brand of the microphone was rode
and the brand oh i'm actually still
using the the mount the thing that holds
up the microphone my brand h-e-i-l feels
very anti-semitic i do not feel safe in
this studio how are they not canceled
tile
is that how you think we're pronouncing
it h-e-i-l
hail
it's giving hitler it's giving hitler
it's giving gurbals
sure gerbils
sure
um
so i'm depressed i'm back in new york i
have a lot of stuff to do this week like
you know work work work i have a show on
friday just wanted to remind everyone my
you know final leg of my not like other
girls comedy tour is officially
officially on sale all this all the
cities a lot of them are gone nashville
good luck charlotte best wishes but we
still got tickets in portland we got
tickets in seattle huntington long
island red bank new jersey alabama sorry
no we're all out because jackie i don't
know if you know this like were
huge in alabama it doesn't surprise me
no me neither like we are real tied war
eagle yeah roll tide rolled
tied exactly you took the words right
out of my mouth um but little update
from last week we our quest to 100 000
youtube subscribers has not been
fruitless like we are at 98.1 as of this
morning that's 900 people that's
literally 0.01 percent of people that
listen to the show if 1900 of you could
just go over to youtube and subscribe
like i could get my [ __ ] plaque
okay okay we're picking a name today i
think it's my dad
yesterday was uh no friday was the
emily's thursday and wednesday we went
biblical we went rachel and sarah and
i'm curious um
who have you chosen jax i think i'm
gonna stick with the biblical i'm gonna
go
rebecca okay
i'm it's my name to choose and just be
glad i didn't choose something you know
gertrude oh my god claudia that's what i
was going to say but i didn't want to
offend the gertrudes
i just have to say like i feel like
gertrude is one of those names that
people are like yeah but it's actually
like a stunning name and if your name is
gertrude like you go by gertie and
that's so cute yeah justice for the
gertrude toasters and you know what if
you're listening gertrude toasters feel
free to subscribe as well yeah today i
think every day we should do a common
name and a not common name because oh i
love that and a lot of people are
feeling like especially people with not
common names are like this is you know
keychain trauma all over again because
my name is never gonna get called but i
i think that's why we need to include
some less common names oh my god i
absolutely love the way your mind works
so yes today we're going with the
gertrudes and the rebeccas okay great
and unstoppable duo name a more iconic
duo
you can't you literally can't so if you
are listening to this episode as a
podcast in whatever format and you find
yourself being named gertrude or rebecca
um it is your civic duty your
responsibility to get your ass over to
youtube.com your morning toast and
subscribe like on your gmail your work
gmail your school gmail that you haven't
logged into in 15 years like get it done
because we're 1900 away i feel like we
should be hitting it this week at the
rate that we're going because every time
we call out a name it's like a couple
it's like a thousand yeah we should be
hitting it this week and so i now you
sort of just need to prepare for
reaching your goal
and how you're going to celebrate
yeah i hope it's not one of those
moments where i'm like so hyped and then
it happens and then i'm just like you
know over it i mean that's exactly what
it's going to be and then you're just
going to be in the quest for 500k but we
can at least pretend that you'll be
satiated by this
yeah for sure and it just makes me think
like in in the one or two weeks that we
were talking about this and we were
doing episodes in florida we've gotten
literally like ten thousand youtube
subscribers and it just makes me think
like where were all those other people
you know every time i was like they'll
be subscribed on youtube you know like
where are they
i wanna hear from the people who still
haven't subscribed and just like let me
know
why maybe it's because you listen in
your car and by the time you get to
where you're going like you have
forgotten the call to action no there
might be like a real reason why and i
just want to know because you guys know
how important it is to claudia and i
know you guys love claudia so if a
equals b and b equals c
then you guys should be subscribing
if a equals b and b equals c like why
the [ __ ] don't we have 100k yeah
oh my god also we haven't even spoken
about how literally after friday's
episode of the toast like so much
happened so much news chloe's baby skeet
and kim like we
their timing it almost feels intentional
and i would be offended if i wasn't
flattered that they were literally
skirting us on a friday um so we have so
much to talk about today which is
exciting we have so much to talk about
today like every story they were
clamoring to be in the fast five and i
had to be really selective about what we
discussed
i i love that like it's better than the
days when we have to be you know really
selective in terms of like should we put
the worst story on the fast five or the
the least the second to last worst story
we usually go for the worst
but that's so us so us and honestly
sometimes you know adele fast five
leaves it open for us to let our
creative juices flow but like on a day
like today we have business to do like
we're here as really reporters
reporting the news we also have unburden
yourselves because it's monday and i
feel like a lot of people had weekends
like you know it's one of those last not
the last but we're in august now final
weekends of summer i think people are
just like losing their minds
um and i fully expect our own burden
yourselves to match that energy things
get crazy in august
i'm using my morning toast tumbler too
for my iced coffee that i really have
been loving drinking thanks to your
influence you guys know i like never
drinking i am using the new weekday
tumbler looks like you're using the og
and by the way i'm loving using tumblers
and because i can do it i used to bring
a tumbler to the studio but then i have
to like go home to dishwash it but now
that
i live at my studio i ordered even more
morning toast tumblers so that i could
just like have a different tumbler every
day and then just wash it
let's talk about the luxury that is
living at the studio because i
definitely took it for granted even
though i wasn't staying at your house it
wasn't like a real commute this morning
like just
i think it also has a lot to do with the
heat like getting out of the house in
full dress like
honestly like i can't it's not for you
no i've seen what it's like to truly
work from home
and
don't get me wrong i don't even have a
real commute it's six blocks like maybe
less actually like it's not a real
commute and i'm still
i'm not loving it once you commute by
golf cart it's really hard to go back to
the way things were
so true it's so true
so true
i'm really missing you i'm really
missing rolled i'm really missing
michaela um quick update if you guys
were following um just kind of the arc
of me and michaela's relationship and i
talked about it a lot in the patreon
just how i am eden session and she is
lisa rinna we made enormous progress
over the weekend and i haven't been able
to update everyone but michaela is now
fully sang auntie um she probably said
it 25 times before i left and i heard
this morning she woke up and said
where's auntie which just made me want
to die
but also made me really because where
the [ __ ] is auntie
such a good question
look
who knows
who knows it's maybe that'll be my
children's book where's auntie where's
that not where's waldo would it just be
like sickening pictures of me like
like in the crowds you know
finance love that for you where's auntie
looking sickening on this beach oh
gorgeous auntie
um
so yeah i had written some things down
oh you know i watched some interesting
television that i wanted to tell you
about oh that makes one of us still
haven't turned a tv on in my house
that's so crazy i watched um
the robin williams documentary it's not
new it's from 2018. um but i watched it
over the weekend and it was so good and
i just wanted to recommend it at first i
was so bored i was like oh my god i
can't believe someone's so funny has the
most boring documentary but
it really picked up and towards the end
i was like really emotional and really
sad and it was just really
really good and when you also i feel
like the um details of his passing were
kind of
low-key
as far as like what he was going through
um but he turns out he had louis body
syndrome which is something i never
heard of and then i started reading a
book and it was in it what book where
this one i found on like prime free i
was like i don't know i honestly it's
like the secrets we keep yeah that's
what it's called i think i've heard of
it
i actually cried i'm not done with it
wow
and it's not even a particularly sad
book there's just like this tragic event
that they talk about in their youth and
when they finally tell you what it is
like it's just like the way it's written
like the girl who's like the victim is
so sad like
her name is alice and she's like this
chubby teenager who's like a loser but
she's like so nice and like something
bad happens to her and it's like the way
they were just describing alice it just
made me cry like she was like queen
that's really sad
yeah and it's only the second i don't
really cry books only second book i
cried at but whatever so with robin
williams
basically like because the whole time in
the documentary i was waiting for like
people who described him who've known
him for so long to be like but he also
you know was really suffering but they
never really brought that up like he was
really always just like fun loving
obsessed with entertaining people kind
of guy so i'm like how does it happen
you know like that and he had louis body
syndrome which is basically like a
mental illness where your brain is
feeding misinformation to you
like just you're straight up lying to
yourself oh wow i didn't like
me neither and it was so interesting and
i never i don't know if that was like
the first time they spoke about it or
people know that i didn't know that um
it was a really good documentary highly
recommended oh wow okay add it to the
content plate i have multiple plates
this is like a 10 course meal at this
point
at the quiet one yeah oh my god i have
so much to watch hopefully one day i
will get 12. and actually i'm at the
point where i need to start writing it
down and i'm just like writing things
down now i'm at the stage in my life
where we're writing things down right
now i'm writing it in my notes app but
that doesn't really work for me i need
like a pattern pen and paper in every
room in my house because i'm constantly
thinking of things and then forgetting
them
should we make merch notepads where like
the letterhead says mogul energy
yeah forgetful mogul energy
because i had a um a list of things to
do on my phone that i was writing down
and i had like a merch idea and it was
mobile energy oh yeah we definitely need
some mobile energy and so do our fellow
moguls you know
there's toasters everywhere and every
time i hear about like a toaster doing
their toasty thing they're just so
impressive
and
we all i think we're all moguls
i think so too the other thing i watched
was cma fest it was televised on abc and
they uh put it on hulu and first of all
just can't recommend watching it enough
a premium experience like everyone
showed up showed out played their best
[ __ ] hits but the reason why i wanted
to talk about it was because do you know
who hosted it
dirks lerks bentley
and l king
and l king
is
l king is reminding me of a conversation
we had last week that i want to talk
about about nepotism basically okay
because i feel like a lot of people
don't even realize not everyone knows l
king she's definitely she and i'm loving
this transition for her she's turning
into like a country girly she performed
her song with megan miranda lambert who
wasn't there but then she performed her
amazing song x's and o's with ashley
mcbride it was so good um so i'm loving
this journey for her and for those of
people who are familiar with her music a
lot of people don't realize that her dad
is rob schneider like the iconic actor
from mostly adam sandler movies
and i feel like she's like kind of like
an iconic nepotism baby because
literally like her parent like her dad
is the best kept secret like no yeah but
i feel like i mean maybe i'm wrong but
just like the way that it's packaged to
the world i feel like her success is
totally
irrelevant from his and it's just a
coincidence that they're related like
that he didn't open doors for her but
that's just because they're in such a
different world and maybe i'm totally
wrong like maybe he's best friends with
darks and darks got her like i don't
know anything but that's just the vibe
that they put out
i completely agree like i feel like
there's literally not one iota of like
help coming from rob schneider to el
king's career i don't know that for a
fact i just feel like
the places that he has influence are not
the rooms that she wants to be in
i completely agree i just wanted to
bring her up because i love her and she
also went on to say yes to the dress and
chose the same thing that's on having
taste
100
also before we get into everything i
started a new book this book that
everyone's talking about every summer
after by carly fortune
and so far
it's fine
but it's like not doing for me what it
was doing for the rest of the world and
same for snitch snitch and i are both
reading it because she almost chose it
for the redheads and i really wanted her
too because i love when we choose like a
trendy book that's so good and then
everybody who reads the book like will
listen to the episode and millions will
listen that's always you know my dream
for the redheads um but she didn't
choose it at the last minute and i was
okay with that because she actually
wanted to do something different and we
always support this niche doing
something different because it rarely
happens
and now i was like okay great now i can
read it and i'm so glad she didn't
choose it it's just like
fine
you know what it's like so sad sure
okay can i say something though like not
to make literally okay don't spoil it or
anything okay i'm not no i'm not i'm
just saying i read the book and
absolutely loved it and i just like
found the book scrolling on goodreads
like it wasn't this hyped up like
everyone's obsessed with like the summer
i turned pretty vibe like i just found
it and really liked it and like raved
about it to everyone and not saying like
i made it trendy but like yeah i
understand that feeling because i feel
like there are so many books that i made
trending
and i can't track yeah i can't attract
them i know it happened one summer you
made that's true i got the wreck from
snitch but i read it before her and i
was like everybody has to read this i
also feel like um
every little
no and then you spoke about it on the
toast and then i read it and we
literally spoke about it for a week
straight like i'm telling you like not
to make everything about us but like
true and also every last secret because
that was a random book that i found on
like kindle unlimited
but that's not like i read it but that's
not like crazy but like every time i see
it somewhere i'm like oh i wonder if
like it trickled down
from my image do you think we made
do you think we made um luckiest girl
alive trending it had the thing is it
had its moment like
three years ago and it was like the
biggest book when it came out and then
by the time we read it was a few years
later so definitely we gave it a little
kick in the pants but it was already a
bestseller
when you buy my book on amazon because
that's also the funniest girl also with
the redheads books all of the like
customers also bought are all redheads
books but wait i actually want to go
on goodreads and see what yours and
that's on amazon using your data no but
using your data to have a positive
effect like if you're going to use my
data like i want good recommendations i
want
to be like have an easier time picking
books okay so i'm going your book on
goodreads
listeners also readers also oh my god
what's my overall rating what's my
overall rating is it bad no i've checked
i don't know
3.95 that's strong that's a four and a
four is good on goodreads
especially considering like how many
people probably just gave you a one star
and didn't read it
to to be like
[Laughter]
exactly also
goodreads since it's linked to your
amazon they should be able to see if you
actually bought the book in order to
give it a rating
just like spotify okay 100
i was just gonna say spotify like
enacting this rule where you can only
rate a spotify if they can i mean you
can only write a podcast
if they can prove like data wise that
you've actually listened to like more
than 30 seconds of an episode is genius
and apple should implement that and all
other rating services should implement
that too even yelp you have to upload a
receipt that's pretty good okay what's
weird is readers also enjoyed are like
all books i've never even heard of right
now
from what on amazon yeah
oh what are they all
are they
blooming in his image ten ways god
in his image yeah ten ways god calls us
to reflect his character
oh my god they're giving not forsaken
maybe your book is like a religious
self-help book love and luck oh big
friendship how we keep each other close
then luckiest girl alive then den of
vipers goodnight beautiful i've never
even heard of these books
okay wait but like me being like a
religious book are you being a christian
icon
not me being an apostle
is that lucas 12 16 or claudia ashrae
it's it's claudia 12 16.
wow
oh my god am i are you maddie pruitt
everyone's quaking over i know i
actually was quaking a little too we
didn't choose it as a story because
who cares
but like
clearly
we haven't spoken about her in a while
but like she really
has become like a motivational religious
speaker and
she's she's taking the sadie robertson i
love her um from
from reality star to uh preacher
and i'm love that charity for her
wishing her the best what i find so
crazy about this whole thing is like
maddie perry has not cut her hair since
the bachelor and i find that so crazy
like as someone who has long hair and
lived with hair down to my butt crack
for like six years and now i look back
and like be like oh my god why did
nobody like help me um i just find it so
crazy that her hair is that long and she
lives in alabama like it's too hot what
do you mean
it's too everything humid
hot
but you know she is engaged to uh i saw
millionaire
and you know what i am truly happy for
her because
there's just nothing better than money
i'm happy for her too also she would
look really great with like really short
hair like a really cute crop
um mm-hmm
yeah length
but i don't think it'll happen i'm just
honestly like i am in awe of her hair i
hadn't thought about it in a while but
you're right
because when they were on the bachelor
they were in a really hot and humid zone
i don't remember where it was the
location in which they were filming and
i could not stop looking at her hair
obviously he was like frizzy as [ __ ]
because she's human and then i just
thought that maybe like she would watch
adam want to cut it but she didn't no
partisan she's growing up oh my god she
might actually be samson part of growing
up is realizing like it's time to cut
your hair
i completely agree when i look back like
pretty much all of high school my hair
was literally built no the thinking was
just like the longer the better the more
the merrier but no
no i used to get a haircut and like trim
half an inch and have mental breakdowns
like literally crying pulling my hair
out in the bathroom i
can't believe i was so mentally ill back
then and i'm so glad i made it and i
feel like when you're younger you have
all this hair and you just like use it
to hide because you're like young and
insecure and you just think like i'll
put some hair on it
no it's true and i think also as like a
chubby young person you really use hair
as like a security blanket and you think
like okay it's hiding all my
imperfections and you look back years
later and realize no it's actually
highlighted it's just adding like
[ __ ] to everything and you
you put it so far in front of your face
you look like you have a beard
and then from the back you have no hair
and it looks like a [ __ ]
like literally put some hair behind your
head [ __ ] it won't hurt you
yeah true i'm not in any position to
talk because right now my hair is
absolutely disgusting and long and
stringy like i have to keep it behind my
oh by the way i'm not saying manipur's
hair is bad all i'm saying is like i
cannot believe it's just still
so long well she's also really young so
maybe she hasn't reached the age where
it's like haircut that's gonna you know
make me mature
that's what happened to me when i was 23
i got a bob and i grew the [ __ ] up
yeah she'll be back in due time
bye
right now with all my hair falling out
and by the way it's like not stopping
it's so crazy how much hair i'm losing
on the daily um
bobby oh could be back anytime soon
cool i'm so ready for her arrival i cut
it myself it's just
but you look great
um okay so yeah i think without further
ado
it's time for the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you
by mcdonald's here at the morning toast
it is no secret that we are obsessed
with mickey d's
after a long day of recording the show
running around doing errands is there
anything better than a mcdonald's
fountain diet coke a crispy french fry
and their iconic chicken sandwich here's
the important question what's the best
mcdonald's crispy chicken sandwich is it
the standard is it the spicy is it the
deluxe and you know i think chicken
sandwiches are more personal than comedy
because
i think the best chicken sandwich is the
standard but that's because i don't
really like to take risks and i'm change
averse but maybe you're a spicy person
who prefers the spicy sandwich you know
but the answer really is all of them um
so personally how i get my sandwich
which people like quake over is just
chicken bread and ketchup and apparently
like people aren't putting ketchup on
sandwiches that's what i learned um
recently when people like blew me up on
social media for putting ketchup on my
sandwich and i thought it was like so
weird that nobody else did so that's how
i do it but it's so personal like how do
you do it pickles no pickles extra
pickles
how do you do it well go to mcdonald's
and be creative explore your inner
cravings
mcdonald's crispy chicken sandwich you
can order it ahead on the mcdonald's app
which is premium as hell and you can try
the sandwich that invented the crispy
juicy tender today at participating
mcdonald's you can download the app and
registration is required um and this is
just your sign i don't know if you guys
needed a sign it's your sign to get your
[ __ ] ass up and go to mcdonald's
okay are you ready for our first story
which is one of the big stories of the
week slash weekend slash the day
yes kim kardashian and pete davidson
break up after nine months of dating the
kardashians star and pete have broken up
and decided to just be friends sources
close to the couple exclusively tell e
news e news was the first to report it
and then everyone else did the insider
shared actually i think the sun was the
first to report it like last week but
then e news nobody believed
the news came through with the source
i thought it was tmz i don't know what
tmz has says but the insider shared that
while the pair has quote a lot of love
and respect for each other they found
that the long distance dynamic and their
demanding schedules made it really
difficult to maintain a relationship the
split occurred sometime this week okay i
don't believe that for one second and i
am shocked by this like i'm more shocked
that they broke up after everything
we've seen in the last nine months than
i was hearing that they were together
and i was so shocked by that i thought
that this was it we've never seen a
happier kim like how do you go from
being that happy with someone like we
saw on the show like we saw you know
they were at the met gala they've been
doing all of these things together going
you know in the bikini modeling on the
beach and just a few weeks later like
done not even like they're in a fight
he's in australia she's in la maybe
they're just like
talking over the phone and texting until
you know they can get back together and
but they're done i'm shocked and i think
something happened
yeah i don't necessarily think that this
was going to be the end-all be-all for
kim but it did prove to be way more
serious than any of us had anticipated
and i thought it would just go on for
longer especially because we just got
the trailer baby want to take a shower
with me like it didn't seem and i know
she just went to australia to visit him
so it didn't really seem like they had
any you know yeah
the idea that like their schedule's gone
in the way is such a lie and so
insulting like first of all kim is so
busy so if he's in australia working on
a movie like that works for her in like
she can like spend the time with her
kids and doing her thing and then when
he's done like they'll
reunite also she has a plane like she
can visit him wherever whenever
i really think like something happened
but i can't even fathom what it could be
no not like a cheese like a cheese like
a
like a just
i don't know
i don't know
i wonder if they'll take him out of this
new season because she's not gonna like
she said on last season i'm not gonna
like you know talk all about my
boyfriend and then if it doesn't work
out and then i'm just like
left there hanging and i feel like
she's not gonna
do a whole season glowing about how
happy she is when we know they're not
even together
it's important to note that um
e-news then released a conflicting
report saying that kim and peter back
together or like they never broke up so
i'm just gonna operate because i think
that if these reports was false she
would post some stuff on her instagram
stories that was like low-key you know
like kevin and devin
ken kevin whatever
like you know posting pictures with
devon and we're like oh they're together
so she would post like even one thing
just to be like shut up we're together
yeah i i don't know what happened and
obviously now everyone is you know
saying that she's getting back together
with kanye but the source who provided
the initial statement about their
breakup also said the divorces
like nothing has changed
that i believe too i don't think
honestly i i do think that kim and kanye
like are irreparable especially given
what happened
after the divorce um
so i don't believe that for a second i'm
just like i'm definitely confused
because
while obviously you know this was an
unorthodox relationship it became so
serious like really quickly and with the
kids and then you know him defending her
with kanye like it got kind of legit so
i just feel like to go from that to a
breakup i was really shocked by and yes
maybe their schedules are bad and he's
filming a movie in australia but like
okay the movie comes right and he left
snl he has more time on his hands he can
live in l.a right what happens to the
tattoos what happens to the brand
to the branding the branding is really
tattoos
people especially celebrities get
tattoos for people they date all the
time and then they break up a week later
so tattoos even though they're
technically permanent are really not
brands branding
is extremely permanent and i don't know
um
what you do i think this was meant to be
a longer term more serious relationship
and i think that like
you know when someone like does
something that they can't take back
or like oh just exhibits like poor
judgment or something
i feel like something weird happens like
that
do you think it involved the kids not
necessarily
because like if pete like did something
like that kim didn't approve of
parenting wise and like like maybe that
yeah but he's in australia what could he
do
or like you know when you like someone
who likes like betrays you in some way
like maybe says something to some like i
i
something little but that indeed
indicates like a whole difference i feel
like it's something
just
it's something it's not scheduling okay
no i hate when people say that like if
people are in nicole richie
not nicole richie if keith urban and
nicole kidman can make the schedules
work as the biggest country star and
most you know
a-list actress in hollywood like nobody
else has excuses
i don't believe the scheduling thing
like especially when you have access and
means to private planes and things you
know us lay people could only do yeah i
i'm really really shocked
yeah and i'm still mad over uh taylor
kitsch and
lady gaga's
scheduling
it's his thing yeah
what was the other taylor kinney okay by
the way same thing um and taylor kinney
like doesn't even work so what schedule
so true
so i'm so excited about the lies
i hate being lied to but also like your
personal life is your personal life and
you really don't owe us like an
explanation so i don't know if we'll get
like a full detailed review of what went
down um and if this really is the end
then like let's
let's let's acknowledge the end like i
think that this was a great relationship
for kim i think she's probably really
grateful for the time she spent with
pete um he brought her out of like a
what could have been like a really dark
place and lonely time into i think what
she says like was what some of the most
fun of her life like she was so happy
so for that we're grateful thank you
pete
why
did it end how does she go from being
that happy okay
you know like i felt like in this in
watching the kardashians it's like she
figured out the key to life is how she
was acting
how do you go from that and then in mere
months to like goodbye good day sir it's
over
well there are conspiracy theories that
like this was kind of like a diversion
type of press moment which we'll get to
because that's the next story but i
don't think it would be untrue
same by the way and i don't think kim is
like so they're not
like as desperate as they used to be
they're not just like throwing [ __ ] at
like this is their personal these are
their real lives they're not like out
here just like making [ __ ] up
for the scene right and okay let's get
to the next race this is what everyone
is saying chloe and tristan welcomed
their baby boy uh last week very
exciting via surrogate as we knew was
going to happen now people are saying
that
the kim news dropped right before
chloe's drop to give sort of chloe a
buffer because we know that she
struggles with like the public
perception of her and she just doesn't
want to deal with that with a new baby
and i just don't think that's true like
first of all
the impact of this news came a few weeks
ago when we found out they were having a
baby now knowing that they had
that doesn't change anything like i
don't think that these two things
were playing off of one another i really
don't because i really don't think this
chloe news is like
even news
because the news came out agreed
i do think though that like
kim and chloe releasing this on the same
day and like late in the afternoon on a
friday before a weekend that was
probably intentional just being like we
don't want to make a big kerfuffle out
of these two things like we just move on
with our lives so to me that's
totally fine like them kind of kind of
wanting to bury their own stories um
because it is an odd time to release
like major news if you're wanting like
the full extent of the press yeah monday
morning but not necessarily that kim is
like doing this to shield chloe i don't
think chloe's on her phone just like on
the show we saw that like kylie deleted
all social media before she gave birth
i'm sure chloe is off social media just
like enjoying
newborn bliss
yeah i agree
i am really happy for chloe like i know
she's wanted a sibling for true
and she got it in an unorthodox way but
life is unorthodox i'm loving the word
unorthodox today that's the third time i
said it um
and honestly like i love this for chloe
i'm sure we won't hear from her for a
little while like because new mama tings
like you know it's very overwhelming
having a newborn and i'm really like i
really am wishing her the best and i
feel like anyone who's not and who's
being like hey
shut up like seriously we don't care
anymore it's not even about tristan like
it's going to be getting percent i'm so
happy for her i'm so happy for her
family i'm happy for true
and
tristan is just irrelevant like sorry
yeah
sperm bang yeah
bye but by
story two subset b and that this is the
news that i'm actually taking really
personally is that chloe and her private
equity investor have broken up quote
things fizzled out the good american
founder has reportedly ended things with
her mystery private equity investor
boyfriend according to multiple outlets
quote chloe and the private equity
investor broke up they split a few weeks
ago things just fizzled out between them
can i say something
the private equity investor sounds like
a made-up character like and by the way
i don't think that he is like the way
that everyone keeps saying like the
private equity investor like it's almost
like yeah no it's he's an individual i
agree because it's like there's other
ways to describe him like go to
thesaurus.com financial person
businessman beau like why didn't they
call him
once they used to say it about everyone
whose husband had a job
until we like co-opted it and ruined it
and now it's a joke
i have to say like chloe having a fling
with someone and then like welcoming a
new child like if the fling wasn't going
anywhere like obviously even if like
unless they're super serious she's not
going to have him around while she has a
newborn and so if they're if he's not
going to be around then she's not going
to see him for a few months because
she's busy with new mama tings
of course and i feel like kind of how
when valentine's day comes around and
you've been seeing someone for like a
short amount of time how valentine's day
can either expedite your relationship or
make her show you that it's not a
relationship
make or break so kind of like a baby
like if you guys were actually like
vibing and thought there could be a
future there you like a baby might you
know
speed that up a little bit it forces you
to take the hardware families
yeah um so if it really was just like
fun fling and now she's going to focus
on her babe i think breaking up is
obviously the right choice and obviously
i'm sad that they broke up because i
want happiness in chloe's life but um
sometimes flings are just that like
flings they bring you you know from one
relationship to the next and then get
you i do hope that chloe enjoyed you
know the
the financial partner experience
and maybe we'll go down that route again
maybe it's encouraged her to seek out
more
private equity investors yes or she just
like knew that's what we all wanted for
her was just to date someone like
average joe so she put so she was like
there you go citizen
yeah and maybe you know she did it for
us but ended up like
she's like i'll shut them up i'll just
go out with this guy
right right and then like she pretends
the whole time it's literally it's
called movie and they fall in love
strangers it's called the business to
enemies
everything is called the businessman bow
that's the truth are you ready for our
next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you
yes yes it is
you need olive and june if you were
going to this wedding this weekend
i'm also nobody to be giving an olive
because i've been like traveling and
have been able to do my own nails so do
as i say not as i do okay
olive and june's press-ons and their
all-in-one press-on-manny system have
everything you need to get a salon
quality manicure in minutes for a
fraction of the cost they have beautiful
nails whenever you want and do them on
your own time so there's no need for an
appointment i've said this once i've
said it again one thing about me is i'm
a press on nail girly like they are
premium and
the olive and june ones like i feel like
really the quality of your press-on
nails can encourage you to either keep
doing press-on nails or if you get like
bad ones you'll be like oh no this is
tacky the olive and june ones are so
premium just because everything olive
and june's like puts out is premium like
their colors are very plenty and pastel
very classy elegant timeless colors and
shapes and olive and june is really out
here doing the most and i'm an expert in
press on nail so you have to listen to
me
um their press-ons come in more sizes
than any other brand so your press-ons
look like your real nails that's the
thing press-on nails are usually for
most brands one size fits all but like i
have short fat fingers jackie has long
thin ones like why would we ever be
using the same press-on nails
um
it's really easy to get salon worthy
nails at home with olive and june they
have the affordable press-on manicures
um that are just
so much better for your wallet than
going and getting tips and they last
just as long so you can visit
oliveinjune.com tmt for 20 off your
first olive in june system that's o l i
v e a n d j u n e dot com slash tmt as
in the morning toast for 20 off your
first system oliveinjune.com
tmt
great our next story other big news of
the weekend teresa and louie got married
in new jersey this past weekend and this
bravo liberties came out so here are the
deeds theresa giudice and louis ruelas
tied the knot in an extravagant ceremony
and reception saturday in front of
family not that much family on trees
aside friends and co-stars the
festivities unfolded in east brunswick
new jersey on the sprawling 15 acre
grounds of park chateau estate and
gardens the picturesque venue boasts a
palatial mansion and adjoining chapel
with an all-around white facade inspired
by the romantic ornate style of 17th
century gothic french art architecture
so the venue put out this press release
yeah this article just has all the
details you know the dresses the
bridesmaids the co-stars so teresa's
four daughters
gia gabriella melania and adriana served
as her bridesmaids along with her
co-stars dolores and jennifer
also the wedding was a veritable who's
who of housewives margaret josephs was
there looking like the snatcher it was a
collaboration between caviar dreams and
the snatcher because oh
my god she looked amazing margaret
looked so stunning i was obsessed with
her hair and her dress if i didn't want
to chop my arms off i would wear that
dress yeah no she looked incredible
jackie goldschneider was also there so
was jill zarin during the medley aya
chanel aion from real house eyes of
dubai alexia from miami lonnie love was
there phaedra was there cynthia kendra
yes so it was a star-studded affair and
we also need to talk about
the hair
okay so let's talk about the wedding
first and then we'll talk about melissa
and jonathan okay
um so i actually uh thought that the
wedding i'm not talking about the way
that she looked the wedding was really
beautiful um and pretty tasteful for
teresa's taste which can be like you
know tacky jersey
vibes and i think she would agree with
that i'm not saying that as an insult
i'm just saying that's like her personal
aesthetic like you know
remember what her house looked like yeah
it was the wedding was you know the
wedding version of her house
yeah
and
that i really like i don't do not like
you know speaking negatively about how
someone looks on their wedding day like
i do think it's really mean but i feel
like because i can acknowledge that i
look like a fat rat at my wedding i'm
allowed to judge others yeah i think
that's fair
and i'm gonna start with the positive
she looked really happy yes she did
her dress was very pretty very simple
her body is you know fitted like a glove
it was a really pretty dress i didn't
understand the gloves because they were
like pearl gloves she looks like she had
you know pimples all over her arm
and then it really matched the aesthetic
of the dress and i love like one of my
favorite favorite
like bridal trends is gloves everyone's
doing gloves i love it so classy it's so
jacky oh like it's so gorgeous
um so for me to hate your gloves they
must be ugly
and they also just like they just didn't
match like whatever
but the thing that's you know on
everyone's lips is the hair she wore her
hair down she has very long hair very
medy pruitt energy okay but it was also
clearly a lot of extensions like this
was
five women's worth of hair
it was a lot of hair it was you know
wavy down to down all the way down and
then she wore a tiara which is so tree
um
and in the tiara was you know a beehive
of sorts i don't really even know how to
describe it it was
giving i mean if you guys ever used to
watch my big fat american gypsy wedding
which was the best show of all time on
tlc like all like the like 18 year old
brides used to wear their hair like that
and they would wear it like so high
above their crown and the crown would
get lost in the beehive um i just
thought it was a really interesting
choice for tree and the more i think
about it like first of all it's like
kind of iconic because like it's so like
it's so jersey
um and so is theresa so teresa is
arguably the most jersey and also
arguably even though they probably you
know don't want to admit it like the
icon of the state of new jersey
yeah her and bruce
bruce
springsteen
literally like when i i think it's a
generational thing like when older
people think of jersey they think of
bruce when younger people think of
jersey they think of tree yeah sure
bruce just like or maybe like men and
women
but see the thing is with with theresa
is that like she gets full glammed
probably three or four times a week
either for filming she goes on watch
driving live she does appearances and
events photo shoots so it must be hard
to then want to look your best on your
wedding day when you pretty much look
your best every year and to top that
and do something different so i think
that was like what she was trying to do
um but she really did fail abysmally but
in a sense like i'm kind of obsessed
like
it's so teresa it's so jersey
and
like i don't know it's kind of working
yeah like the more i think it's kind of
iconic but it is my personal philosophy
that like you should obviously look
gorgeous and feel amazing on your
wedding day but you should still look
and feel like yourself so like if i were
tree like the watch what happened to
like live hair that's just like waves
classic traditional like that's what i
would have gone with um it doesn't need
to be much more than that but not when
you're teresa judice and like you're
having uh by the way this is a special
that they're doing on bravo for the
wedding like it was pretty star-studded
with bravo liberties i think people who
are like obsessed with bravo were
following the wedding weekend the way
that like we back in the day followed
andy's baby shower like it was an event
like that that was iconic for people and
she gave the people what they wanted
which was the absolute most
and she gave us something to talk about
because i have not stopped thinking
about that hair since i saw it and at
first i was like what the [ __ ] this is
so weird and now that i've really been
able to marinate in it i think it might
be unintentionally one of the most
iconic things she's ever done yeah also
like maybe this is just one of those
things that's like before it's time you
know like right now
she's not appreciated in her right now
like we don't get it it was like those
jeans kim was wearing it's like i don't
get it i'm not i'm not forward thinking
and then in a few years like all the
girls are gonna be wearing this
hairstyle and it's like
and we didn't get it when she did it
first
i don't think that's the case i just
think it's like really camp like it's
almost like
it's too much like i actually think like
it's amazing if now that i've like
really been able to sit with it of
course my initial reaction was that of
everyone else was like what the [ __ ] is
that but now i'm like
i'm thinking like this might be the most
iconic thing tree has ever done like her
daughters must be so proud yeah i agree
like this is now she has like a few
things that are like so tree
this is the table flip then the hair
yeah
i love it i'm so glad
no i really like it's been a journey for
me to get to this place but now and i'm
glad we didn't speak about it like if
the wedding was on friday because i
would have roasted her on friday but now
that i've really been able to you know
look at it from the big bang theory i
think it's
i think it's like um here's the thing
and it's so big you could see it from
the big bang thing right it comes out
this isn't one of those things that gets
lost in the bank theory perspective no
it's really not it's literally a meteor
i'm just praying for her neck today
i know it must have been and imagine
like dancing kissing like louie dips you
and your neck snaps and you tumble over
yeah
you stumble under the weight of it all
her daughters looked beautiful um their
dresses were really pretty their glam
was glam their hair was great it looked
like a you know
a nice affair it was kind of sad though
that like
jennifer aiden was a bridesmaid because
like bridesmaids are people like you're
like true lifelong friends and of course
like you have a new friend you know
maybe you'll make her a bridesmaid but
for her
two
bridesmaids besides
her kids to be delores obviously and
then like a girl she met two years ago
three years ago yeah
well i don't know i won i just don't
think teresa has a lot of like deep
meaningful friendships and that's
because she's not a deeper meaningful i
agree with that sort of first of all
i'm curious where dina manzo was she was
supposed to be a bridesmaid she's
teresa's really good friend but then she
wasn't there some people don't really
know why but some people said maybe it's
because she didn't want to be on the
show
unclear but i do think that's weird i
also i thought that like louis sisters
were going to be bridesmaids and then
obviously the elephant not in the room
is melissa gorga she should have been a
bridesmaid but i just want to say before
we talk about melissa like i'm fine with
jennifer being a bridesmaid like her and
theresa really are that close sometimes
you just meet people in your life and
even though you've only known them for a
year but now jennifer it's like four or
five years
you just know that that's your that's
your person and i and i like that for
her
okay
but melissa and joe not being there
first of all like
and i'm the first person like i'm super
family oriented i'm the first person to
be like you know work it out work it out
family first
but you do reach a point
with with someone as toxic and
narcissistic as theresa where like there
is no talking to them and you have to
put your own like mental health your own
sanity and your own family first
and so while i'm never like supportive
of like families breaking up i actually
am extremely supportive of melissa and
joe not going to this wedding it is a
huge
yes i'm supportive of that but the
details are that a few days before the
wedding they had their season finale
event and like something bad happened
and theresa and louis betrayed melissa
and joe in like in a whole new way i
guess there were rumors about melissa
and joe's relationship flowing up
flowing at the party and theresa and
louie like did not behave as as family
should and that was the line for melissa
and joe and they're done
that's that's interesting and uh what i
had heard was that melissa and joe and
teresa louie got a huge fight because
melissa and joe were really urging
louie and uh teresa to sign a prenup oh
but i don't think they wouldn't go over
that i think especially after everything
that theresa has like done to them both
subconsciously and consciously and
conscious um
i don't think i think the fact that they
put their foot down like right before
the wedding it's like you put up with
all this for so many years and now like
this woman is really having like a simra
and she's so in love and i actually
think that louie is like the right guy
for her and that their relationship is
good and and i think that melissa and
joe would say the same and probably
endorse their marriage like now is when
you're gonna take a stand like
you know but i'm very here for them like
you know protecting their person but
like their kids weren't there and like
that's their cousins and
but you know what like there's really no
way to get through to teresa to like
show her that you have hurt them yeah
and maybe the way that like they thought
would would do that is something so big
like not going to wedding and you know
what like i
i don't like i just i do i'm with joe
and melissa i am with you i'm with joe
melissa by the way 100
i know and i know what you're saying
like why now and like it's such a big
event and it's such a big deal but like
maybe that's the only way they thought
they might get through to theresa like
we are actually so mad at you we're not
gonna come to this and we're not gonna
bring our kids yeah that's very true but
just for me i'm like we could all fight
after like you could be done with her
like after her wedding it's just you
can't ever take that back in a few years
if you all make up and if that's even
possible
you will always not have been at the
wedding
will was joe supposed to walk her down
the aisle
did that was that a conversation
i don't know that's something that he
would do she would love that
right yeah well that would be like even
more serious then
right
um i'm just like i'm here for this like
i have first of all i think it's gonna
be great for the show obviously and two
like as someone who watches the show and
like sees how
horrendous it is to be related to
theresa judith like i'm actually proud
of these two for like putting themselves
first for the first [ __ ] time
and not just swallowing it because
family family family like eventually
like you have to put up boundaries and
like when it comes to family i think
it's really tough for people to put up
those boundaries with toxic people and
people live with those toxic
relationships like forever yep
but you know what like it's time i agree
with that it's time it's just like kind
of
a weird time to finally make that choice
when it's it is you know a big occasion
for teresa but in general i might i am
here i'm but something might have yeah
they said it's something
i'm so curious to see what it is and
talk to me once we've watched it and
let's see if i've changed my opinion
i had seen and i don't like to like give
light to like bravo theories because
like they're always wrong but
what people had been saying online was
that there were rumors recently about
infidelity um on melissa that's the
rumor that i think teresa and louie are
giving light to and the way that they
confronted it at this season finale
party was the unforgivable betrayal
well if anything this is just great
promo for the new season of jersey which
never disappoints really truly
disappoints
and i'm super surprised margaret and
jackie were both invited and both
attended
we'll see we shall see but yes it does
make for interesting
fodder
and i just think it was time honestly i
agree with that
okay our next story another crazy story
anne
is in stable condition after being
severely burned in a car crash
a rep for the actress told people in the
statement on saturday that anna's
currently in stable condition her family
and friends ask for your thoughts and
prayers and to respect her privacy
during this difficult time
so
anne crashed her blue mini cooper into
several buildings before it caught fire
a few days ago over the weekend
according to tmz bystanders tried to
help the actress out of her vehicle
after she crashed into a parking garage
however she allegedly backed up and
drove off before crashing to another
home where her car became engulfed in
flames as did the home that she crashed
into the woman lost all of her worldly
possessions
aerial shots of the incident show the
actress being taken away on a stretcher
her clothes and her back look visibly
burned it is presumed that heish was
under the influence of alcohol as a
bottle with a red cap was spotted in her
car shortly before the accident however
lapd could not confirm this detail then
this morning i saw that they did get a
warrant to check her blood alcohol
levels uh from the crash a blood sample
from the crash so they will know more
soon um
by the way this is such a crazy story um
and people uh like witnesses are saying
you know she was running riding around
town speeding like an animal through
like residential neighborhoods before
she ended up in a
garage and then in someone's house um
and i have to assume nobody drives like
that if they're sound of mind
so
she must have been under some sort of
influence and i think this is so [ __ ]
up and honestly i've never been in an h
stand in my life and i never will be um
and i think i don't really know like who
anne hey she is i just know like a lot
of people know her because she used to
be married to ellen right
i know her because she was on joan
rivers season of celebrity apprentice um
and she was
mean as [ __ ] to jesus goodbye i don't
even remember her on that season
she got out early she got out early she
was mean to joan it's disgusting
everyone was [ __ ] mean to joan
because they were so threatened by her
talent of course and she won so they
should they were right to me right
what was that other one annie the poker
player danny
duke yeah
annie duke who came runner up she was
[ __ ] mean to joan but joan was so
[ __ ] mean to her i think the meanest
thing i've ever heard anyone say is
something joan rivers said to annie duke
on
she said she's so self-centered hold on
actually i don't want to watch it just
hold on
joan rivers
also um i thought you would want to know
that peter faucinelli spoke out about
the an heish
accident because they they start
together on something that we've never
seen and he was sending his thoughts and
prayers oh
so i thought you wanted to know where
peter fox's thoughts were today
no that's that's very interesting i also
saw an article like a lot of celebrities
are getting [ __ ] for like commenting you
know words of support like for for and
annie and heish like alex oh yeah but i
mean what she's done is atrocious and
especially if she was under the
influence i'm glad that she's okay and
that nobody was hurt but she destroyed
that woman's house
no it's terrible
okay wait this this is it
hold on the movie they're in together is
13 minutes
excuse me peter fox
13 minutes
oh i thought you said the movie was only
13 minutes long yeah
you said the movie they're in is 13
minutes i'm like oh what movie is only
11. it would be your favorite movie yeah
of course
i can't find it but
it was just very like a very clever way
of insulting someone you [ __ ] okay
well you'll have to find it at a later
date and put on a canva portagraphic
she said oh she said
annie duke is the type of woman to spit
on the ground and drown her mother
it was rough like queen queen queen chin
um
so uh ann hey share on my list you guys
know how i feel about people who drive
under the influence and this is really
bad really bad
and i've never thought of ann hayes i've
never thought of putting her on any of
my lists because she's irrelevant to you
yes i just looked at her catalogue i
looked and she has so many movies and tv
shows that she's done i actually can't
find one that i've seen
okay are you ready for a fifth and final
story about movies that are not
irrelevant
top gun maverick has no now flown past
titanic at all time domestic box office
however this headline is misleading but
it still is you know a big
deal tom cruise's sequel top gun
maverick is now the seventh highest
grossing movie of all time at the
domestic box office after adding to its
ticket sale totals this weekend the tom
cruise sequel has now made 662 million
at the domestic box office again that's
domestic not global surpassing the
titanic 660 million according to variety
however titanic's number includes both
its original theatrical run and several
subsequent re-releases in theaters which
makes it more but it hasn't been
adjusted for inflation
right right right of course like when
titanic came out a movie not a nickel
but maybe like ten dollars in the 90s
and now a movie is like
or 30 so
it's different yeah but i thought it
would be interesting to go through a
list of the most highest grossing movies
of all time in our fifth and in our
fifth and final human interest story
can i guess some how many movies are
there in the list
okay uh
and so titanic and top gun are in there
avatar
yep that would be that yep that's in
there
the most recent spider-man no way home
yeah
wow that's really big yeah it's here
um let me think let me think let me
think what else does james cameron
produce and direct
um
oh
thanos you know that one avengers
avengers end game number two yes
okay okay so number one is star wars the
force awakens
two avengers end game three spider-man
no way home for avatar five black
panther six avengers infinity war seven
top gun maverick and now eight would be
titanic
i'm gonna titanic got pumped but i
really don't think it's fair to
like you can't compare movie sales
in the early 2000s no you really can't
you really really cannot and if they
adjust it if for inflation titanic they
need to adjust the list for inflation
because what are we talking about
otherwise
yeah no that's dumb as [ __ ] but it is a
big milestone this is tom cruise's first
movie to uh cross over to the one
billion
dollar box office and so i'm sure he's
feeling pretty pleased with himself
i'm like annoyed because i loved top gun
and i wanted it to be successful but i
didn't want success for time i feel like
i know you have to say that when you're
talking about top gun which you loved
um but i feel like
you say that you don't like tom cruise
and then privately like you like him
oh my god i feel like you feel like you
have to say something negative about tom
cruise when he comes up because you've
watched all the scientology docs and
like but that like privately
you're fine
oh that's so funny uh no like i i watch
going clear i watch leah remini like
he's literally like i haven't watched
any of those things so i just go off of
what you say and it just doesn't it
hasn't like stuck for me yet and like so
many people love him like and everyone
who was
i don't think they do like the top gun
cast mates like kelly's always posting
like the cutest tick tocks with him and
miles on the red carpet and it's like
it does things to you
i know
no i know but like i'm
from all the research i've done like no
bueno and you feel that way about john
travolta
okay that that one is really difficult
for me like
to separate the art from the artist
because i'm like obsessed with look
who's talking i loved greece i loved his
work as edna turnblad like
it's it's actually harder for me to like
understand
and also like all that he's been through
like he lost his son and then he lost
his wife like i have like
like a soft spot for john travolta
even though i but see
when it comes to scientology and like
the rankings like i do think john
travolta is like you know a part of it
and he's all in there but tom cruise is
like
administrative like he's gather he's
donating money he's raising money like
he's a part of the foundation of
scientology do you know what i mean like
he's one of the top top executives
whereas like john travolta is like a
member you know john travolta is pretty
tops but okay
no i i definitely have a hard time like
the way you think
that i feel about tom cruise is actually
how i feel about john travolta like i
actually forgot sometimes that he's a
scientologist because like i have like i
have deep love in my heart yes for adele
dazeem you know
it's
no it's hard there are some things that
you just can't reconcile
in life
like
taylor start with celebrities who either
like
kim and taylor celebrities who like do
and say things that like i vehemently
disagree with but like i still love them
you know i think that's okay
yeah i think not everything is just
gonna be tied up in a neat little boat
like some things pose like a moral
contradiction for you
no it's so true like especially when
it's like you know something that
contrasts your scruples that's what
scriptures are all about
yeah my scribbles yeah you try
we all try that's really all we can do
at the end of the day is try our best
to uphold our scruples the truth and
that's what everyone
and that's what everyone who wrote into
deer unburdened yourselves is trying to
do so those were the past five stories
you definitely needed to know like each
you did everything you really did i'm
hoping i hope you're still here
listening
and our next segment the show is not
over is unburden yourselves if you ever
want to write in every monday we do one
burden yourselves where people can write
in and just kind of admit and just like
kind of verbal diarrhea things that are
holding them down embarrassing things
they did falls they took you know
unburden yourselves at gmail.com and it
is brought to you by seed it turns out
that everything you know everything you
think you know about probiotics may be
wrong
we knew that probiotic tortilla chips
sounded like way too good to be true but
good news is that seeds daily symbiotic
is the real deal so what is the daily
symbiotic it is a broad spectrum two in
one probiotic and prebiotic it is 24
strain broad spectrum probiotic and
prebiotic that is formulated for
digestion gut immune and additional
system systemic benefits it's a capsule
in capsule protects against stomach acid
against digesti it helps digest your
enzymes and bile salts for viability
through digestion
what does that mean the live probiotics
will actually make it to the end of the
small intestine for delivery into the
colon if you've taken a probiotic before
and you never felt a difference it's
likely because the good bacteria doesn't
survive in your gi tract see it is
designed differently and that's why it
works it supports benefits in the gut
and beyond seed will support ease of
bloating health regularities and ease of
evacuation if you know what i mean but
it will also support your gut barrier
skin health heart health and
micronutrients
synthesis so if you're into probiotics
and you felt like you've taken them
before and there wasn't like a real
change or a real difference i really
recommend trying seed you can start a
new healthy habit today when you visit
seed.com toast and use code toast to
redeem 20 off your first month of seeds
ds01tm daily symbiotic so that's
seed.com toast and use code toast
um
check it out it's always a good time to
start taking care of your gut and all
the other amazing benefits
from a probiotic now i'm ready
yourselves jax are you ready
hey girly girls i need to unburden
myself
this incident happened last week my
first week at a new job my coworker and
i were going to lunch so i went to the
bathroom on our way out of the office i
felt rushed so i decided to try and use
the little pee hole in my spanx shorts
i started to pee while holding this
stupid pee hole open and pee not only
gets all over my hand but soaked my
spanx i had to take them off and go
commando and obviously i had to hold the
wet spanx when i walked out of the
bathroom to my new co-worker who was
waiting for me i rinsed them in the sink
she obviously noticed the folded spanx
in my hand so i told her it was so hot i
couldn't pull them up and then grab my
purse from my desk and stuff them at the
bottom [ __ ] my life thank you for
listening xoxo a toaster who peed
herself i don't know i just feel like
women no matter the workplace like women
understand like you didn't even have to
explain to her whether it was hot or
whether you peed yourself like there's a
general under like if a girl i was with
went to the bathroom and came out with
like literally like a dirty tampon i'd
be like girl i've been there you know
like we've all been through this is very
relatable i think at the end of the day
it might foster connection between the
two of you and then in a few months
you'll look back at drinks at happy hour
and she'll be like oh my god i knew you
were a real woman you just took your
spanx off and then you could tell her oh
no i actually peed myself and by the way
this is just a psa like those holes are
not meant to be peed through i never use
pee holes like that i nev even when i'm
wearing a body suit like i actually take
it off i know a lot of people pull it to
the side but like
it's not worth the risk i just want to
say pulling to the side with like a
bodysuit or a hot control top underwear
is a flawless system i've actually ready
for this i'm gonna unburden myself i
have pooped pulling to the side like
pulling to the side isn't extremely just
too risky
it's not but i do want to say like if
this girl is like judgy and weird she's
actually doing you a favor by letting
you know she's not a girly girl and
really not someone you should like
invest in a friendship with because if
someone's being all weird and judgy like
even if you did [ __ ] piss your pants
or if let's say you [ __ ] sharted okay
[ __ ] happens so she's gonna be all weird
and be like oh you're taking your snake
bye like you don't need to spend
literally
and i actually think more people should
walk out of the bathroom holding their
spanx and see if you're surrounded by
real ones or not
this really isn't that embarrassing
because either you've made like a a bond
with a potential new friend or she's
given you like a telltale sign that
she's yeah and she's not a woman who
supports other women and she's
definitely not a beautiful woman
right and she's kind of a disgrace to
women who are actually beautiful and
classy and she just doesn't have the
vernacular that she thinks she possesses
somebody lied to her several times and
told her that she was fly hot and sexy
and beautiful and she's nothing like
that she's not i hope we understand
yeah no you have really nothing to be
ashamed of
next up morning morning jackson claude
every week my daughter's school sends
home their sheets and blankets from nap
time to wash the sheet is a fitted sheet
so things get all caught up in there in
the dryer
anyway i sent it to school
i sent it to school with one of my
thongs lodged into the corner and was
really confused when my thong came home
in her school bag it took me a few hours
to connect the dots but i wanted to
crumble into a ball i mean listen real
teachers know and these
right was it a male 1 how did the
underwear look and you know what i think
it's better that it was a song and it's
like cute as a po and it's like oh this
girl's like cute sexy mom versus like a
big pair of bloomers
okay so like obviously i'm putting
myself in her shoes like if a pair of my
underwear made it out into the wild
without my guidance
um like i would i would literally have
to like enter the witness protection
program yeah it's because what
because my personal style of underwear
is like the bigger the better you know
the more it looks like a hospital so
it's like underwear that was like once
white and is now
top
what
mustard
yum
mustard like
yeah i would just hope it was one of the
good ones one of the good ones
one of the good ones okay so like you
really are fine jackie's totally right
and my only concern is that like did the
teacher think that like you know
the teacher obviously saw it in the bed
sheet i think the teacher probably has
seen a lot of stuff
and
i think that the teacher is gonna let
this one go don't that's just honestly
really funny just find someone that you
can laugh about it with the thing is is
like
this is one of the things you have to
learn the hard way like oh [ __ ] gets
caught in my
folded fitted sheet the corners of my
fitted sheet like now every time i wash
it let's just triple you know shake it
out make sure nothing nefarious
like a really funny story you could go
tell it at like the pta over drinks and
everyone will want to be your friend
i really don't think it's a big deal
especially if the teacher is a woman
like yeah and when teacher smiles
happy
i think this made teacher smile
all right ready
oh for sure like you know just being a
teacher is such hard work and every now
and then you just got to laugh and you
gave her that kind of reprieve
you know the teacher's just like tired
of like putting up with kids duties p's
like they're snot they're boogers and
it's like
this song is the last straw
last straw like maybe you're the one
yeah no like the final nail in the
coffin that broke her
you push teacher too far
ready okay ready for our third and final
hello jax brothers aren't you
how can we unburden ourselves
thank you guys for being the highlight
of my week we can't wait to see claudia
again for the second time on her end log
tour in pittsburgh can't get enough need
to unburden myself i can't stop thinking
about what i did and i need to atone for
my sins i feel as if there's no better
place for me to do that than here
i was in trader joe's this week and was
very focused on completing my grocery
list due to my intense focus i spaced
out and grabbed another person's cart
and rolled it to the other side of the
store
i realized shortly that it wasn't my
card and without thinking i just went
back to find my cart and planned to
return the stranger's cart to the
location i found it well as i went to
find my card this woman probably in her
70s was making a huge scene and
aggressively raising her voice as her
car about her car being stolen as soon
as i saw her causing a scene i literally
ran to the opposite side of the store
and grabbed and decided not to expose
myself as the cart thief i literally
pretended to shop all the aisles i
already shopped to actively avoid this
woman i could literally hear her from
the other side of the store making a
huge commotion i couldn't expose myself
about 10 minutes later she found her
card it was on her way oh my if her
purse was in there
that's what i was thinking too if it's
just like food it's really that's like a
neutral territory it's in it's like yeah
no it's not honest and it's interesting
and annoying but i understand wanting to
like protect your piece but if she
thought she lost her purse and you had
her purse and you didn't like bring it
closer to her and show her how to get
warmer um and instead like really gaslit
her
into thinking your cart was stolen then
that's that is mean yeah but
i have to say just from reading it i get
the vibe okay there's no person it's
just like an inconvenience and she'll be
okay
yeah but if there was like a wallet in
there
um like yeah and i just would have
placed it
closer to her not on the other side of
the store
or just like return it to the front or
something i'd be like if only if there
was a bag in there but you know what
like when you zoom out from the big bang
theory like she'll be fine
like it's fine completely it's not like
the best thing a person can do but it's
definitely not the worst no it's not
even close
no and the good thing about the
the good thing about the grocery store
is like
you're all strangers it depends
on what you work with like you
she'll probably never see this [ __ ]
again it can't be that small if there's
a trader joe's
so just go to whole foods now
thank you all for opening up being
honest and vulnerable with us this is a
reminder if your name is gertrude
or rebecca it is your day to subscribe
on youtube from your burner account your
work account your mom's account
um and that's our show anything else we
need to like remind people to
i mean you can always head over to the
redheads you can always follow me on
instagram jackie ashrae and you can
always tune back in tomorrow for another
amazing show
you can
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
[ __ ] subscribe
don't yeah
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so
spotify itunes stitcher public video i
have read a cat box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys all have an
amazing monday don't forget to rise and
grind with bras and straps and we'll see
you tomorrow